[Musik]
keine Blume entfaltet ihre Schönheit in
einem derart gigantischen Maßstab
jeden Frühling tauchen aber Milliarden
von Blüten die Niederlande in einen
Rausch von Farben soweit das Auge reicht
diesmal bitte best doch diese Blume hat
eine geheime Geschichte
ihre Schönheit für vielen armen Tage
Diebe ebenso wie steinreiche Herrscher
ihre Zwiebeln wurden in Gold aufgewogen
3 ihre unglaublichen Muster und
Farbstellungen zogen im frühen 17
Jahrhundert eine ganze Nation in ihren
Bann
[Musik]
it baut sie wurde zum Objekt von
haarsträubender Spekulation
[Musik]
die Preise stiegen in astronomische
Höhen
doch schon nach kurzer Zeit stürzten
tausende ins Unglück als die Preise
plötzlich ins Bodenlose fielen
es war die erste Spekulationsblase der
Weltgeschichte
der Tulpen Crash Julie
[Musik]
Niederlande februar 1637
die Nachricht verbreitete sich wie ein
Lauffeuer
[Musik]
zum ersten Mal hat er eine tulpenauktion
nicht den erwarteten Preis erzielt
in den letzten Monaten waren die Preise
um mehr als das Hundertfache gestiegen
doch jetzt wollte plötzlich keiner mehr
Tulpen kaufen alle Wertpapiere waren
wertlos geworden
der Traum vom Reichtum dauerte nur kurz
er beruhte auf dem Handel mit einer
wahre von äußerst unbeständigem wert
dennoch hatte das tulpenfieber weite
Teile der niederländischen Bevölkerung
erfasst alle wollten von der Gier nach
den bunten Blüten profitieren
doch jetzt war alles aus
[Musik]
besonders hart traf es jene die von
Anfang an nur über geringe finanzielle
Mittel verfügten
denn an der Tulpen Spekulation hatten
sich alle beteiligt
einfache Handwerker Bedienstete
Tagelöhner oder Spieler
Menschen wie der Müller Adrian
[Musik]
es war verrückt eine richtige man nie
eine echte Spekulationsblase es machte
ja auch wenig Sinn auf den ewig
steigenden Preis einer Blume zu wetten
Peter im Garber ist Ökonom und Analyst
einer internationalen Großbank ein
Parallelen zwischen dem tulpenfieber und
dem Geschehen an aktuellen Börsen sind
nicht zu übersehen
damals wie heute wetteten zu viele
Menschen auf eine viel zu hohe
Preisentwicklung
bleibt die Frage wieso fallen wir seit
Jahrhunderten immer auf denselben
Mechanismus herein der britische
Historiker Mike Dash hat dafür nur eine
mögliche Erklärung
es gibt etwas im menschlichen Denken
dass uns davon abhält die Wahrheit über
börsenblasen glauben zu wollen
an einer Spekulationsblase beteiligen
sich die meisten wieder besseres Wissen
dieses Phänomen wurde bei der
Tulpenmanie des frühen 17 jahrhunderts
erstmals sichtbar
Holland nahm in der ersten Hälfte des 17
jahrhunderts eine absolute
Ausnahmestellung in Europa ein
während der 30-jährige Krieg den Rest
des Kontinents verwüstete erlebten die
Niederlande ihr goldenes Zeitalter
es war die Zeit der großen
niederländischen Meister wie rembrandt
franz
Rubens
und viel mehr
dank des Überseehandels boomte die
Wirtschaft und beispiellosem Ausmaß
kostspieliger Königsherrschaft regierten
in den Niederlanden Bürger und Adel über
autonome Städte und Provinzen
man muss sich klar machen dass die
Niederlande im frühen 17 Jahrhundert
etwas ganz Besonderes waren es war das
erste Land in Europa mit moderner
Wirtschaft und das reichste Land Europas
dieser Reichtum beruhte auf Handel es
war das erste Land das umfangreiche
Handelsbeziehungen mit dem fernen Osten
unterwegs und von dort standen die
meisten Luxusgüter indem sie die Profite
für sich behalten konnten wurden die
niederländischen Händler außerordentlich
reich
der Reichtum blieb zum größten Teil in
den Händen Weniger aber auch für den
Rest der Bevölkerung war der
Lebensstandard höher als anderswo in
Europa
[Musik]
die niederländischen Händler hatten im
vorangegangenen jahrhundert die
Reformation durchlaufen Holland befand
sich unter Einfluss einer ziemlich
extremen Form des Calvinismus dadurch
war jede offensichtliche zur
Schaustellung von Reichtum verpönt die
reichen konnten ihren Wohlstand nur in
einer Form demonstrieren die auch Gott
verherrlichte daher stand die
niederländische Leidenschaft für Gärten
ein begehrtes Schmuckstück der
holländischen Gartenbaukunst war die
Tulpe eine Pflanze die aus den fernen
Zentralasien stammte
[Musik]
in den kalten Städten und
Gebirgsregionen Kasachstans blühen bis
heute die wilden Vorfahren der
holländischen zuchttulpen
[Musik]
sie sind etwas kleiner und zeigen viele
prächtige Farbschattierungen von rot
über orange bis Geld
[Musik]
von Zentralasien aus gelangte die Tulpe
zuerst in die Türkei wo sie als Vorbote
des Frühlings besonders verehrt wurde
die Blume kam in der zweiten Hälfte des
16 Jahrhunderts nach Europa in den
Gärten Kaiser Rudolfs des zweiten
gelangen die ersten nachsichtungen mit
dem Botaniker Charles erreichte die
Tulpe schließlich die Niederlande
[Musik]
an der Universität Leiden gründete le
clues auch Clusius genannt dem
Blumengarten hortus akademicus wo bis
heute die Nachkommen von Clusius ersten
zuchttulpen zu bewundern sind
die exquisite Blume sollte ganz Holland
in ihren Band ziehen
so auch den Müller Adrian
[Musik]
er spielte gerade eine Runde Trick Truck
als ihm das lebhafte Treiben im
Hinterzimmer der Gaststätte auffielen
[Musik]
diese Menschen Schiene mit etwas zu
handeln mit etwas äußerst wertvollen
[Musik]
sofort wurde klar dass hier ein reger
Austausch von Geldstücken und
Tulpenzwiebeln stattfand
und jeder konnte mitmachen
Adrian witterte seine Chance
[Musik]
wenn sie in Harlem aufgewachsen sind und
Müller waren und versucht haben auf der
Grundlage ihres Wissens über diesen
Markt vorherzusagen was der zukünftige
Preis bringen würde können sie sich
irgend
[Musik]
jede spekulative Investition ist vom
Wunsch getrieben möglichst hohe Gewinne
zu machen das tulpenfieber war da keine
Ausnahme
wie gewöhnlich waren nur die Bedingungen
unter denen dieser Handel stattfand
es war eine Art von parallelwirtschaft
die damals unter Handwerkern und Bauern
entstand diese Leute wussten nicht genau
wie man so etwas machte sie bildeten
ihre eigenen Börsen wobei sie sich im
Gasthaus trafen der tulpenhandel fand in
einer bierdunstatmosphäre statt dadurch
ließen sich die Leute wohl auf höhere
Risiken und auf weniger seriöse
Geschäfte ein
zuerst wurden die Zwiebel gewogen
der Verkäufer schrieb den gewünschten
Preis auf eine Schiefertafel und übergab
sie dem Vorsitzenden
dann schrieben die Interessenten ihr
geboten nieder
[Musik]
der Vorsitzende legte dann den
Verkaufspreis Fest der irgendwo zwischen
den gewünschten Preis und dem höchsten
Gebot lag
[Musik]
Adrian schlug zu er hatte soeben sein
letztes Geld für eine kleine braune
Zwiebel ausgegeben
[Musik]
einer gab wahrscheinlich beim
Investieren den Ton an und der Rest der
Herde tat es ihm gleich allein aufgrund
der Tatsache dass diese Person in ein
bestimmtes Vorhaben investiert hat
alle steckten ihr Geld in dieses Projekt
oft ohne zu wissen worum es dabei geht
auch Adrian hatte noch nie zuvor mit
Tulpen zu tun gehabt geschweige denn
welche besessen er wusste nur dass diese
Zwiebeln immer begehrter wurden
[Musik]
was ich in den Hinterzimmern von Harlem
abspielte war der erste Vorbote einer
gigantischen Industrie
[Musik]
80% aller weltweit verkauften Tulpen
stammen heute aus den Niederlanden
im Frühling überziehen bunte
blumenbänder die Landschaft bis zum
Horizont
[Musik]
doch die Blüten aus diesen
farbenprächtigen weiten werden Holland
niemals verlassen werden die bunten
Streifen in der Landschaft sind Felder
Felder zum Anbau von Blumenzwiebeln
nachdem sie verblüht sind werden die
Tulpenzwiebeln wie Kartoffeln aus der
Erde geholt gereinigt und sortiert
bei diesem Vorgang werden die
Tochterzwiebeln der Tulpe von der Mutter
Zwiebel getrennt das diese
ungeschlechtliche Form der Vermehrung
werden zusätzliche Zwiebeln für die
Zucht gewonnen
[Musik]
auch in den niederländischen Gärten des
17 jahrhunderts wurden die Tulpen nach
der Blüte aus der Erde genommen
[Musik]
damit sollte verhindert werden dass sich
Wühlmäuse oder anderes gefräßiges Getier
über die saftigen Zwiebeln der
luxuspflanze hermachten
was ein weiterer Zweck der alljährlichen
zwiebelernte war schon damals die
Gewinnung von Tochter Zwiebeln um neue
identische Exemplare einer bestimmten
Sorte zu erhalten
[Musik]
allerdings erforderten die kleinen
Tochterzwiebeln im Umgang ein gewisses
Geschick
[Musik]
keiner hatte bemerkt was eine davor die
Füße gefallen war
[Musik]
jetzt hielt sie ihre eigene kleine
Zwiebel in Händen aus der sich im
nächsten Jahr gewiss eine Blüte von
höchster Schönheit entfalten würde
aber niemand sollte davon erfahren
an alle verpackte die unscheinbare
Preziose sorgfältig und versteckte sie
in ihrer Kammer
[Musik]
Ihr Schatz sollte wohl behütet bleiben
Adrian auch Adrian schätzte tulpenz
[Musik]
jetzt im Sommer waren die Preise
erheblich gestiegen
je mehr Menschen sich an der Spekulation
Beteiligten umso schneller kletterten
die Preise Adrian bot seine kleine
braune Zwiebel zum Kaufland innerhalb
kürzester Zeit hat er einen schönen
Schnitt gemacht
doch es kam darauf an in welche Art von
Tulpen man investierte
[Musik]
heutige Tulpen unterscheiden sich
erheblich von denen in den Niederlanden
des 17 jahrhunderts sie waren damals
noch viel bunter und farbenprächtiger
der Wert bemaßlich an den Farben und der
Zeichnung je feiner die Zeichnung einer
Tulpe umso begehrter
[Musik]
bis heute gibt es Tulpen in
extravaganten Farbstellungen und
fantastischen Mustern
und auch viele der Gefahren denen die
empfindlichen Pflanzen ausgesetzt sind
haben sich im Laufe der Jahrhunderte
kaum verändert
[Musik]
es sind nicht nur naschhafte
Hausgenossen die den Tulpenzwiebeln
schaden können
[Musik]
tief in den Zellstrukturen der Pflanze
verbirgt sich ein winziger Feind
ein Virus
[Musik]
heute sind diese Viren gut erforscht
aber im 17 Jahrhundert sorgten sie für
viele Überraschungen bei den
tulpenzüchtern denn das Virus kann das
Aussehen einer Pflanze radikal verändern
sobald es in sie eingedrungen ist
die Viren sind ja als Organismen selbst
nicht lebensfähig
die können sich nur in der Pflanze als
Wirtszelle überhaupt vermehren
Margit Leimer der Kamara makado ist
Spezialistin für Pflanzenviren
die Viren sind darauf spezialisiert die
Pflanzenzelle umzuprogrammieren und
dabei kommt es meistens dazu dass das
pflanzeneigene Programm ein bisschen
durcheinander kommt
das kann bedeuten dass einige Gene
Stärke ausgebildet werden und die
anderen total abgeschaltet wenn Sie das
auf die Farbpigmente in der Blüte
umlegen dann gibt es Zellen in denen das
Virus bewirkt dass die Farbstoff
Synthese angekurbelt wird dann gibt es
diese dunkelroten Streifen oder die
Farbstoff Synthese wird ausgeschaltet
und dann gibt es nur noch diese hellen
weißen Streifen
die dann eben dieses besondere Muster
ausmachen
Pflanzen werden auf verschiedene Weisen
übertragen
aber dieses spezielle tulip breaking
Virus wird von Blattläusen übertragen
eine Blattlaus saugt an eine infizierten
Pflanze und überträgt es dann auf eine
gesunde da kann man sich vorstellen wenn
in einem Feld viele Tulpen beieinander
stehen wie schnell das mit sich bringt
dass das ganze Feld infiziert ist
für die tulpenpflanze selbst ist diese
Virusinfektion mit der Zeit eben letal
[Musik]
bis heute ist das Virus ein massives
Problem in der tulpenzucht
und es muss händisch bekämpft werden
diese Tulpenzüchter patroullieren durch
die Felder um verräterisch aussehende
Pflanzen zu entfernen und so eine
Ausbreitung der Krankheit zu verhindern
diese Virusinfektion sorgte aber auch
für die extravagantesten Tulpen des 17
jahrhunderts die hochbegehrten
geflammten Exemplare mit Streifen und
gekräuselten Rändern
um eine schöne Blume hervorzubringen
braucht man eine Zwiebel und die
seltenen die Zwiebel umso höher ihr Wert
aber wie könnte eine völlig neue und
einzigartige Art von Tulpenzwiebel den
Preis eine stattlichen Hauses erreichen
wie es in den Niederlanden der Fall war
das liegt an der Fähigkeit der Zwiebel
sich zu vermehren
[Musik]
die Aussicht auf Verdoppelung oder
Verdreifachung des Wertes einer Pflanze
durch die Ernte von Tochterzwiebeln
beflügelte die preisfantasien
über die biologischen Grundlagen dieser
Reproduktion war aber noch kaum etwas
bekannt allerdings wurden die Tulpen zu
dieser Zeit bereits nach Sorten
katalogisiert
[Musik]
die Natur der Zwiebel macht die Tulpe zu
einem idealen Handelsobjekt sie kann
monatelang außerhalb der Erde überleben
Zwiebeln sind leicht zu transportieren
einfach aufzubewahren und brauchen wenig
Pflege eine Tulpenzwiebel ist ein
Speicherorgan das Tulpen und andere
Verwandte Gewächse eben anlegen um
unwirtliche Zeiten zu überdauern
das kann eine lange Trockenperiode sein
das kann aber auch eine sehr lange oder
kalte Winterperiode sein
eine gewisse Zeit bei niedrigen
Temperaturen ist sogar Voraussetzung für
das erneute Wachstum
[Musik]
erst wenn danach Licht Wärme und
Feuchtigkeit im richtigen Verhältnis auf
sie einwirken treibt die Zwiebel aus
[Musik]
bin in kurzer Zeit entsteht eine im
Vergleich zur Größe der Zwiebel riesige
Pflanze
[Musik]
in der zweiten Hälfte des Jahres 1637
wurden für seltene geflammte Tulpen
Preise von mehr als 100 Gulden pro
Zwiebel erzielt das war der Gegenwert
von vier fetten Schweinen oder 500 kg
Käse um möglichst extravagante Muster
und Farben zu erzeugen wurden die
abenteuerlichsten Methoden angewandt
manche versuchte da die Blütenfarbe
durch Einlegen der Zwiebeln in Rotwein
zu manipulieren
[Musik]
heute werden professionellere
Zuchtmethoden angewendet der Ausgang der
Bemühungen ist allerdings immer noch
ungewiss
trotz genauer Berechnungen mittels
Computer kennen die Züchter oft nicht
das Ergebnis wenn Sie verschiedene
Sorten miteinander kreuzen
stattdessen werden mehrere Varianten
kombiniert und später jene Nachkommen
ausgesucht die besonders schön und
widerstandsfähig sind doch bis es soweit
ist es Geduld gefragt
ist eine Tulpe zum ersten Mal blüht
Vergehen ja
[Musik]
manchmal können die Züchter erst ein
Jahrzehnt nach der Erstbesteigung die
Qualität einer neuen Sorte beurteilen
[Musik]
waren durch die Natur ihrer Zwiebeln
zwar leicht zu handeln und zu
transportieren aber die Zwiebel hat auch
einen großen Nachteil man merkt ihr
nicht an wie ihre entfaltete Blüte
später aussehen wird
der Kauf einer Zwiebel war daher eine
Sache des Vertrauens
Vertrauen das oft genug missbraucht
wurde
der tulpenhandel setzt ein gewisses
Vertrauen voraus es ist aber viel und
schwer abzuschätzen die Quellen sind da
eher dürftig wie viel die Leute
tatsächlich von dem glaubten was man
ihnen erzählte
das Geheimnis dass jede Tulpe bis zum
nächsten Frühling in sich trägt machte
jede Art von Handel zum Glücksspielen
manche Züchter versuchten durch penible
sortieren und katalogisieren die Risiken
für böse Überraschungen in Grenzen zu
halten elfpark nicht auszudenken wenn
ein Missgeschick die sortierten Zwiebeln
durcheinander brachte
[Musik]
even with Park doch selbst bei bester
Organisation blieb immer ein Restrisiko
[Musik]
die wertvollsten Exemplare waren durch
das tulpenvirus infiziert doch diese
Veränderung war für die tulpenhändler im
zwiebelstadium unmöglich zu erkennen
der Umstand dass die Pflanze infiziert
ist macht es sehr schwer vorherzusagen
was geschieht wenn Sie das nächste Mal
blüht
sie könnte eine dieser unglaublich
wertvollen geflammten Tulpen werden oder
eben nicht
der Zufall spielt eine große Rolle bei
diesem Transaktionen was Sie für eine
gewisse Art von Geschäfte Machern noch
attraktiver machte
[Musik]
die umvertrauen aufzubauen benutzten die
Händler die meisterliche niederländische
Malerei auf eine neue Art
eine der erstaunlichsten Dinge aus den
Niederlanden der 1630er Jahre waren die
tulpenbücher diese Bücher wurden oft im
Auftrag reicher tulpenhändler
angefertigt sie bestellten bei Künstlern
Darstellungen der Tulpen aus ihrem
Sortiment
heute sind tulpenbücher unsere
wichtigste Quelle dafür wie die
begehrtesten Variationen ausgesehen
haben oder wie sie sich die Künstler
vorgestellt hatten
[Musik]
diese Bilder zeigen Tulpen von
unglaublicher exotischer Finesse aber
man musste eben glauben dass die Person
die einem das Bild zeigte auch der
Besitzer der entsprechenden Zwiebel war
aber selbst dann blieb viel Raum für
Täuschung
[Musik]
neben den spektakulären Darstellungen
übertraf man sich mit möglichst
distinguiert klingenden Bezeichnungen
manche Tulpe hieß Admiral van der Reick
oder rot von leiden
[Musik]
man kann mit Recht sagen dass die
tulpenbücher eine frühe Form der Werbung
war
die Bücher wurden als Reklame Medium
eingesetzt
wie ein Katalog um Leute zu überzeugen
mancher der Händler hatte noch nie in
seinem Leben eine echte blühende Tulpe
gesehen auch Adrian studierte gebannt
die meisterhaften Darstellungen
[Musik]
knapp 300 Jahre später funktioniert der
tulpenhandel natürlich ganz anders an
keinem Ort der Welt werden heute so
viele Tulpen gehandelt wie am
Blumenmarkt von alsmeer die Halle ist so
groß wie mehrere Fußballfelder
Milliarden von Pflanzen werden hier im
Jahr durchgeschweißt die Verladehalle
arbeitet wie eine perfekt
synchronisierte logistikmaschine denn
Schnittblumen sind eine extrem schnell
verderbliche Ware
[Musik]
die Blütezeit von Tulpen dauert nur
einige Wochen im Frühjahr um die
Erntezeit auszudehnen werden
Schnittblumen in Glashäusern gezogen
dort können sie kontrolliert in mehreren
Etappen zur Blüte gebracht werden so
wird die tulpensaison erheblich
verlängert
um den handelsprozess zu beschleunigen
wird auf den blumenbörsen wie als mehr
nach dem Prinzip der holländischen
Auktion versteigert
dabei wird von einem festgesetzten
Höchstpreis heruntergezählt
der Zeitpunkt des Bietens ist
entscheidend
bietet man zu früh ist der Preis
möglicherweise zu hoch wartet man zu
lang schnappt einem ein anderer die
wahre vor der Nase weg
der Handel hier beruht auf tatsächlich
existierenden Blume Geld und wahre
wechseln zeitgleich vor Ort den Besitzer
ein echter Sportmarkt und genau das ist
der Unterschied zu den handelsmethoden
die sich im Herbst 1636 verbreiteten
[Musik]
und dafür ist der Wachstumszyklus der
Pflanze verantwortlich
[Musik]
im Herbst müssen die Tulpenzwiebeln in
die Erde gesetzt werden damit sie im
Frühling wieder blühen können
man legte besonderen Wert auf das
Arrangement der verschiedenen Sorten und
Farbstellungen
das setzt allerdings voraus dass die
Zwiebeln korrekt sortiert wurden und
nicht durcheinander gekommen waren
auch für alles geheime Zwiebel war es
jetzt Zeit wieder unter die Erde zu
kommen
[Musik]
eine Tulpenzwiebel kann auch im Topf
blühen wenn sie ähnlichen Bedingungen
wie im Freien ausgesetzt ist
[Musik]
entscheidend ist dass sie über den
Winter eine Kältephase durchläuft in
alles ungeheizter Stube dürfte das kein
Problem gewesen sein
[Musik]
blühen ein zwei Wochen im Frühling
danach können ihre Zwiebeln ausgegraben
werden und als Ware einige Monat lang
gehandelt werden
über den Winter müssen sie wieder in die
Erde sonst sterben sie
jede Art von Handel mit den Zwiebeln im
Herbst und Winter war naturgemäß ein
Geschäft in der Zukunft
die Zwiebeln wurden geliefert wenn sie
im Juni wieder aus dem Boden kamen
die tulpenhändler saßen also im Winter
ohne Ware da um auch diese Phase zu
nutzen erfanden sie eine neue Art des
Handels
für Leute die mit dem zwiebelhandel Geld
verdienen ist die Aussicht nur ein paar
Wochen im Jahr Geschäfte machen zu
können wenig verlockend die logische
Antwort darauf war mit den Besitzrechten
einer Zwiebel zu handeln
die Art wie die Niederländer das
Umsetzten ist faszinierend sie erfanden
etwas dass wir heute Termingeschäft
nennen
die Preise der Zwiebeln selbst bewegten
sich nicht so stark die Preise bei
Termingeschäften stiegen enorm und
entfernten sich immer mehr vom Kassa
Preis
[Musik]
das war der Beginn einer neuen Ehre
man konnte jetzt auch mit Dingen handeln
die man noch gar nicht besaß
[Musik]
man kaufte nicht die Zwiebel selbst
sondern das Recht sie zu einem
bestimmten Preis zu erwerben wenn sie
wieder geerntet wird
man bekam ein Papier wonach diese
Zwiebel aus diesem Garten einer
bestimmten Person gehört und wenn man
das Papier überreichte würde man die
Ware erhalten
in Kneipen Hinterzimmern hatten die
Niederländer mit ein paar federstrichen
und Blättern Papiere eine virtuelle Form
des Handels erfunden
um die Abwesenheit des eigentlichen
handelsguts erträglicher zu machen
konnte man sich anhand der prächtigen
Darstellungen ein Bild machen während
die erworbene Pflanze noch irgendwo in
der Erde schlummerte ab und zu bis zum
Oktober waren das reine Futures mit
terminpreisen
der Käufer hatte das Verlustrisiko
ebenso wie die Gewinnchance
viele der für den Handel verwendeten
Papiere sind bis heute erhalten
[Musik]
anhand der historischen Dokumente wird
nachvollziehbar wie schnell sich der
Handel mit den Wertpapieren von den
eigentlichen waren den Tulpenzwiebeln
entkoppelte
als Folge stiegen die Preise in immer
absurdere Höhen
die Zwiebeln sind wie Münzen für sie die
Papiere wie Banknoten sie haben
keinerlei Interesse an dem Pflanzen mehr
noch von den wachsenden Tulpen ging eine
Gefahr aus denn die Papiere die den
Anspruch auf eine Zwiebel bekundeten
wurden fällig sobald die Pflanze aus der
Erde gezogen war zu diesem Zeitpunkt
brauchte man eine große Summe Geld es
war viel besser mit den Papier nur zu
spekulieren und am Ende jemand anderen
Zahlen zu lassen der Handel wird dadurch
immer schneller und hektischer
[Musik]
den Spekulanten war dabei klar dass sie
mit fantasie-preisen handelten aber die
Versuchung immer noch einen nächsten
Profit mitzunehmen war einfach zu
[Musik]
Großhandel und das zeigt schon das
Ausmaß der damaligen Unsicherheit
darüber dass der nicht sein könnte außer
Wind daran kann man erkennen dass einige
Leute sehr wohl wussten die unsicher
diese Geschäfte mit der Zukunft
eigentlich waren
in principle das Prinzip hat sich bis
heute kaum geändert wenn die Preise
steigen setzen alle auf steigende Preise
this works das funktioniert umso besser
wenn der Wert den ein Papier
repräsentiert keine Entsprechung in der
Wirklichkeit hat oder wenn ihn die
meisten Marktteilnehmer nicht genau
verstehen
[Musik]
zusätzlich angeheizt wurde die
Spekulation durch die Tatsache dass der
Eintrittspreis in den Markt im
Verhältnis zu den Gewinnmöglichkeiten
relativ gering war
die Beteiligten waren in der Regel sehr
arm sie verpfändeten ihre Besitztümer um
Anzahlungen auf Tulpen zu leisten sie
kauften einen Schuldschein vom Besitzer
der Tulpe dabei war immer nur eine
Anzahlung fällig ein Weber der seinen
Webstuhl für 25 Gulden verpfändete
konnte den Gegenwert von 25 Gulden in
Tulpen kaufen zahlt er aber nur
zweieinhalb Gulden an er wusste aber
dass er den vollen Betrag in der Zukunft
zahlen müsste die Preise stiegen aber so
stark dass das niemanden abschreckte
also investierte jeder alles was er
hatte in so viele Zwiebeln wie möglich
und hoffte dass er die 90% Restschuld
weitergeben konnte bevor die Zwiebeln
wieder aus der Erde genommen wurden
[Musik]
das wird erst zum Problem wenn sich
niemand mehr findet der einen höheren
Preis zu zahlen bereit ist dann bricht
Panik aus und die Preise fallen ins
Bodenlose
der Definition nach ist eine Blase eine
Situation in der ein Preis eines
anlageguts sehr schnell steigt und dann
zusammenbricht
etwas ähnliches ist im Zuge der
US-Immobilienblase im Jahr 2007
geschehen
[Musik]
doch zwischen Dezember 1636 und Januar
1637 stiegen die tulpenpreise noch mit
unter ins Astronomische
Chroniken bezeugen den rasanten
Preisanstieg die Preise für viele Sorten
verziehen oder für 20 Fakten sich
innerhalb weniger Wochen
das rief natürlich auch Diebe auf dem
Plan
die Wohlhabenden mussten ihre Blumen
Beete mit Alarmanlagen schützen
nachts Gruben Diebe die begehrtesten
Zwiebeln aus um sie auf den Markt zu
werfen
oder sie besorgten sich die Pflanzen für
die sie bereits Schuldscheine ausgegeben
hatten
die teuerste Tulpe war eine Sorte namens
semper augustus bereits in den Jahren
vor dem tulpenfieber wurde ihre Zwiebel
angeblich für 3000 Gulden gehandelt doch
inzwischen war der Preis auf 10.000
Gulden gestiegen um diesen Preis bekam
man ein prächtiges Anwesen in der
nobelsten Gegend von Amsterdam aber
niemand hatte sie jemals gesehen die
semper augustus ist ein interessanter
Fall sie ist die berühmteste Tulpe jener
Zeit wurde aber offenbar niemals
gehandelt man kennt niemanden der die
Pflanze gesehen hat und wir kennen auch
den Namen des Besitzers nicht wir wissen
nur dass eine Chronik erwähnt die Blume
wäre irgendwann verkauft worden
wie von vielen anderen Sorten lagen den
Händlern auch von der semper augustus
der immer fröhlichen Tulpe lediglich
Abbildungen vor
[Musik]
auch Adrian bezahlte immens hohe Beträge
nur für ein farbenfrohes Versprechen auf
Papier
[Musik]
man kann in einigen tulpenbüchern
Darstellungen der semper augustus finden
es ist aber sehr unwahrscheinlich dass
der Maler die Pflanze jemals wirklich
gesehen hat und mal ehrlich wenn man
diese Tulpe mit einer anderen dieser
herrlich fein gezeichneten Tulpen jener
Zeit vergleicht sieht man keinen
Unterschied aber wen interessierte das
bei den Deal ging es um Profit nicht um
eine Tulpe gut möglich dass die semper
augustus nur ein Mythos war
allerdings war die semper augustus wie
alle der hochbegehrten fein gezeichneten
Tulpen das Ergebnis einer Virusinfektion
und damit ein völliges Zufallsprodukt
serratilitisch könnte auch die Zwiebel
die in alles kalter kemente auf den
Frühling wartet zu einer der wertvollen
Tulpen heranwachsen vielleicht war sie
schon eine reiche Frau und wusste davon
noch nichts in der Farbe baut
wenn man Zuwachs will steckt man seine
investierbaren also die echten
Ressourcen in riskantere spekulative
Projekte und Technologien
oft verliert man dabei und hinterher
sieht es dann aus wie eine Blase
oder man gewinnt
im Januar 1637 wurden die Anleger
langsam nervös die Gefahr war dass man
zwar einen dieser Schuldscheine besaß
aber nicht das Kapital die 90%
restverpflichtung zu bezahlen das
erzeugte eine heftige Handelsaktivität
wir wissen aus den Quellen jener Zeit
das in diesen sogenannten
wirtshauskollegien manche Zwiebeln
zehnmal pro Tag den Besitzer wechselten
alle versuchten die Verbindlichkeiten an
jemand anderen loszuwerden das trug
natürlich stark zu Dynamik des
tulpenfiebers bei
manche wie Adrian begannen bereits über
fallende Preise nachzudenken
er könnte im Sommer billig Zwiebeln
kaufen und dann bei der Übergabe den
jetzt stark erhöhten Preis kassieren
doch die meisten hofften die Schulden in
die sich gestürzt hatten mit den
Profiten durch weiter steigende Preise
ausgleichen zu können sie konnten es
sich nicht leisten auszusteigen und
solange die anderen ähnlich agierten
sollten eigentlich alle profitieren
natürlich wird diese Erwartung an einem
bestimmten Punkt zur Illusion
doch dieser Zeitpunkt ist nicht leicht
zu erkennen die fein
ich dachte die Tulpen Spekulation in den
Tavernen sei nur ein Trinkspiel das die
Demoralisierung der Gesellschaft
widerspiegelt das war nicht ernst
gemeint es wurde zwischen Leuten gemacht
die sehr wenig Vermögen hatten und daher
sehr große Wetten miteinander
abgeschlossen ohne Aussicht auf weitere
Wetten
moderne börsenbroker stehen immer noch
vor dem selben Problem wie die
tulpenhändler des 17 jahrhunderts
wann ist der richtige Zeitpunkt für den
Ausstieg
es ist ein extrem schmaler Grat zwischen
maximalen gewinnen und katastrophalen
Verlusten der Wendepunkt ist der Moment
in dem die Preise ihren Höhepunkt
erreichen und kurz bevor der Markt in
einen verkaufsrausch verfällt ein Moment
der extrem schwer vorhersehbar ist
[Musik]
als die Spekulation im Herbst und Winter
1636/37 ihren Höhepunkt erreichte war
sie ein reiner Wettmarkt und kein echter
reale Anlage gemacht
dann kam der Moment mit dem niemand
gerechnet hatte
Anfang februar 1637 fand eine Auktion
für Tulpenzwiebeln in einem Wirtshaus
statt und zum ersten Mal gab niemand ein
Gebot ab der aktionator senkte den Preis
aber auch beim zweiten Versuch boten
niemand das war noch nie vorgekommen
aber die Folgen waren allen Teilnehmer
der Auktion klar sie wussten dass etwas
sehr schlimmes geschah die Nachfrage
nach Tulpen war komplett zum Erliegen
gekommen
in diesem Moment wurden tausende von
Träumen zerstört die Menschen waren
fassungslos und entsetzt schwankten
zwischen plötzlicher Erkenntnis
Verleugnung und Unglauben der Moment der
Wahrheit hatte wie ein Blitz
eingeschlagen
sie stürmten aus dem Gasthaus beschworen
ihre Freunde zu verkaufen die Panik
verbreitete sich und die Preise für
Tulpen vielen praktisch auf Null
aus Panik wird eine wilde Flucht die wir
seither bei jeder Spekulationsblase
gesehen haben
beschleunigt durch moderne
Kommunikationsmittel kann eine platzende
Blase zu einem Strudel werden der
Privatvermögen Banken Industrien
Währungen und Volkswirtschaften aufsaugt
und das soziale Gefüge unserer
Zivilisation zerreißt
in zeitgenössischen Publikationen wurden
die tulpenhändler verspottet scharf
kritisiert sogar mit Affen verglichen
diese Bilder drücken die Frustration und
Wut der Massen aus die sich betrogen
fühlten seitdem scheint sich nichts
geändert zu haben
Fieber war die erste Spekulationsblase
überhaupt im frühen 17 Jahrhundert
konnten die Menschen nicht wissen dass
die Blase sich nicht unendlich ausdehnen
kann so etwas war nie zuvor geschehen
die Tatsache dass die Blase
unausweichlich platzen würde war ihnen
völlig unbekannt
nach dem Plätzen der tulpenblase waren
die niederländischen Behörden gezwungen
eine Regelung zu finden es wurde wie so
oft danach auch ein Schuldenschnitt
verordnet
nachdem Kleinanleger geschöpft
verzweifelt und frustriert waren könnten
die Behörden eine Revolution befürchtet
haben
[Musik]
lediglich 10%, die Höhe der Anzahlung
mussten bei Fälligkeit eines Papiers
beglichen werden manche Kontrakte wurden
gleich für null und nichtig erklärt
der Grund dafür dass es keine
wirtschaftliche Notlage gab war das ist
keine fehllokation von realen
Investitionsmitteln gab
heute ist die Finanzspekulation tief in
der Gesellschaft verwurzelt der Knall
einer platzenden Blase wird auf der
ganzen Welt wieder heilen und die
gesamte Gesellschaft erschüttern
[Applaus]
heute immer noch genau dieselbe Art von
Spekulationsblasen und trotzdem machen
die Menschen immer dieselben Fehler
Adrian musste seinen Traum vom Reichtum
begraben und in seinem Beruf als Müller
zurückkehren
[Musik]
und auf dem Fensterbrett des
Dienstmädchens Anne blühte eine
extravagant geflammte Tulpe nur wenige
Wochen zuvor hätte diese Pflanze sie zu
einer reichen Frau gemacht
doch jetzt war sie einfach wieder was
sie schon immer war eine wunderschöne
Blume und ein Symbol für den Frühling
[Musik]